you know we would be in florida right
now under a normal scenario reacting to
all of the things that were done
on tuesday at the annual meetings one of
the things that was done on tuesday at
the league meetings expansion of the
playoffs we'll talk about that coming up
but most importantly because of the
covet 19 pandemic one of the big
questions for the national football
league will the league start on time
will the games be played will they be
playing in full stadiums it's
inconceivable at this point chris that
it could happen but nfl general counsel
jeff pass on a conference call held with
several media members yesterday
afternoon he was resolute he was
determined now the caveat is we're
planning that's our expectation we're
going to have a full season 16 games
full stadiums that's our plan he cited
some modeling that was done for the
ownership group regarding where the
pandemic is heading and where it will be
in the fall it feels optimistic to me
and i hope that behind that optimism
there is hard planning for all
contingencies in the event that you
can't have a full season but i was
stunned by how calm and resolute jeff
pasch was in delivering his expectation
and the league's expectation that a full
16th season a 16-game season will be
played as scheduled in full stadiums
yeah i i mean i'm with you too there
doesn't seem to be any wavering from nfl
leadership that you know anything else
is going different we hear little you
know rumors here and there but for the
for the the most part
it's steadfast on the normal offseason
nfl schedule
and hey i understand that compared to
major league baseball hockey basketball
hey the nfl can continue business as is
for the most part right now because
they're not entertaining we're not
playing our sport
it's off season stuff it's still a
schedule that we can get away with get
getting accomplished in the nfl you know
at home or via skype or zoom or facetime
whatever it may be and also you know
these owners they have proof in the
pudding too that you know we had a we
had no off season what was that the 2011
off season mike okay well football went
on that next year and everybody watched
it and it was a really exciting season
so you know to me those are things you
know that i think the nfl is looking at
right now but you know i'm with you a
little bit is this realistic i mean i
just don't know as it sits here right
now i have a hard time thinking we're
gonna get in at least a full pre-season
and a full nfl season uh right off the
bat i know maybe that changes in the
next month or two but i don't see it
happening right now
i almost feel like they've decided to
take the position that they're not going
to show any wavering any hesitation any
pessimism regarding the plan to go
forward with the full season essentially
trying to speak a full season into
existence by just saying every step of
the way we plan to do it we plan to do
it and that's fine as long as you have
contingency plans that you're not
sharing with everyone have a worst case
scenario have every scenario mapped out
i've been arguing this for the past week
chris one of the reasons i threw out an
admittedly goofy idea of taking everyone
to some isolated area and playing the
season there in a series of practice
fields in a giant dormitory where all
the players and coaches and all
necessary personnel would be that was
put out there just to rattle the cage to
make sure that people are thinking about
what happens if we can't play a full
season what happens if some cities can
have full stadiums some cities have
empty stadiums all of the what-ifs need
to be identified and basically every
date on the calendar needs to be
assessed if we can't get back to normal
until this day what happens if we can't
get back to normal until this day what
happens and i hope that behind that very
calm facade that we saw yesterday from
jeff pasch we plan to go forward it's
almost like there's nothing going on i
mean that was the irony of it on the
same day that we got the gravest
assessment yet from the daily press
briefing from the white house that's the
day that we just got a sense of
nonchalance from the nfl and i don't
want to say nonchalance but i kind of do
because that's kind of how it felt it
was kind of like wait wait a minute like
as i was hearing him explain it it's
like wait a minute this is kind of a big
deal like and and i know how fast the
off season goes april becomes maybe
comes june becomes training camp and
it's here before you know it
and and maybe they're privy to some
information that the rest of us aren't
and if so good because it sounds like
they're getting pretty good information
and that's my big takeaway chris the
best news of having a full football
season in full stadiums beginning as
scheduled thursday september 10 when we
be in kansas city for the chiefs to hang
their banner and start their title
defense the fact that they're able to do
it is the best news because that would
mean that great progress has been made
in fighting this horrible disease
well yeah i'm with you
the the leadership coming from the nfl
is it's not my favorite i can't lie
about that you know again it seems right
now that hey we're just going to embark
on our normal course here nothing's
going to stop us it doesn't matter we're
the nfl we're the money-making machine
that's what we do hey it's great right
now we don't need practice you know
we're getting a lot of work done we're
the only show in town as far as what
people are talking about talking about
draft stuff free agency stuff so that's
great you know but yes lack of
leadership at time again the
commissioner works for the 32 owners
it's not always in the best interest of
everybody involved in a league he's more
worried about pleasing his 32 guys and
that to me is where you know it gets
lost in translation sometimes about lack
of leadership so that bothers me and
then mike let me bring up this point too
you know
as we sit right now it sounds like we're
not gonna get a vaccine or anything like
that for you know 12 what are they
saying now 12 18 months from now still
is that still the timeline uh i've heard
for 14 months but you're in the range
you're in the range right in the range
okay so we're gonna go with the nfl
season as is i mean okay now it's week
three somebody in the dallas cowboys
gets covered 19 in the locker room i
don't know what what are we going to do
not this the cowboys aren't going to
play or we're just going to say screw it
hey team sorry we're a team we're all
getting covered 19 together i mean so
that that to me is where i just don't
know how you can plan as is right now in
the nfl when the world might throw you a
curveball a team a curveball a play or a
curveball what if tom brady got covered
19. knock on wood i don't want that to
happen mr brady but what if he did i
mean that to me is just the things that
the nfl has to start spitballing and
where we're going to go with this
and here's the the the bigger reality
the coven 19 is the illness that is
manifested by the coronavirus you can
test positive for the virus and be
asymptomatic what do you do with a guy
who's perfectly healthy think about that
right perfectly healthy but he's tested
positive for the coronavirus so he can't
play for two weeks so all of a sudden
tom brady is gone for two weeks even
though he's fine it's not affecting him
in a negative way at all he's not
allowed to play until he's coronavirus
negative now i think the hope is chris
by september there will be quick and
easy ways to test and everyone would be
tested on a regular basis there will be
an antibody test from what i've heard
before too long where it's a quick prick
of the finger and you can find out
whether or not you've already had it
which would mean you're good to go in
the event that someone in your locker
room test positive so there's a lot of
issues a lot of questions and that's the
thing this idea that i will be fine
you know okay will you be fine though i
mean yeah right what do we what do we
like i mean i think it's okay to say
we may not be fine or we don't know
we're taking it one day at a time like
everyone else it just was an odd message
i understand
the desire to go full speed ahead and
this is an area where the selfish
interests of the nfl make as much money
as possible and i'm a capitalist i got
no problem with that mesh with the idea
that there is a greater good that is
accomplished by playing nfl games and i
believe that i believe that's more
important the idea that people will have
that that normalcy in their lives that
thing that we can rally around that
shared experience is going to help us
from a mental health standpoint if this
does continue into the fall but the
problem is if this continues into the
fall how in the hell can you play the
games so that's where it stands and
i just look i'm going to continue to
take a wait and see approach and one
thing we're going to wait and see chris
is the schedule release because usually
it comes out before the draft something
that was said yesterday during this
conference call with reporters may 9 at
the latest is when the schedule will be
out so i look it's going to be after the
draft that that never happens well it's
going to happen this year and i'm fine
with that take a little more time apply
a little more flexibility and also also
in this wasteland of no sports don't
don't burn off your schedule release
shows a week before the draft when
everybody's thinking about the draft
hold it for a couple of weeks because
it's going to be an even bigger deal if
nothing's going on because it's already
the top story when the schedules come
out even when you've got the nba
playoffs starting the nhl playoffs
starting in the mlb season starting it's
still a big deal when we find out the
when to go along with the who and the
where of the 256 regular season games
yeah well where does it go though mike i
mean okay so we have a schedule may 9th
that's great you know i get it but
you're right i mean
what's the contingency plan going to be
you know if we have two weeks gone or
one city still in in a hot spot
environment to where the coronavirus is
really spreading in a in a way that they
can't control it i mean we could still
be seeing that at that time of the year
to where what are we going to do tell
teams not to go play
games in that city whatever it may be i
just think there's so many things
unknown i'm okay with the nfl you know
acting as if it's business as normal for
the most part right now and they're
going to continue to trudge ahead with
the normal things they do i understand
all of that uh what i don't understand
is yeah i would like or i don't i don't
need to understand it i just wish i
heard more contingency plans i think
that's the one thing that's frustrating
coaches i think coaches that i talk to
around the nfl and stuff and you know i
got too much time on my hands here
talking to them yeah they're frustrated
with where this is going to go too
they're they're going to keep working
and doing what they got to do as far as
evaluating players and everything that
way but you know i think they're
concerned for their family and you know
their players on their football teams
too here as we get into training camp
just not knowing you know where we're
gonna be at is it gonna be realistic to
ask guys to get together a hundred guys
in a locker room hey coaches who are
older you might have an old offensive
coordinator who has an asthma problem
now he gets colvin 19. whoa that could
get dangerous so you know there's just
so many things here yet that we just
don't know about and uh you know i'm
just worried i'm worried that the nfl
season will not be complete this year
yeah and i i just i worry that that as
we start peeling the onions some of the
issues you're raising like what if they
can't play games in one state they can
play them in another state right right
who's is it going to be like the saints
where you're on the road for every game
of the year like it were in 2005. like
and when will there be a sense of okay
we know how this is going to go i feel
like it's going to be potentially day to
day weeks week that's why my admittedly
crazy idea of taking everybody to some
place in the middle of nowhere and
sealing it off from the outside world
now you got to get food i mean you know
they have to get to work on the garden
and the cows and the chickens and all
that if they want to be self-sustaining
but they could call it at some point we
can help
at some point you're only going to be
playing games in areas that are safe to
play games and then will there be any
areas like that look and i don't want to
be an alarmist i don't want to be a
pessimist i just want to be realistic
and i don't want us to all get our hopes
up that they're going to be football
season and then we get to july or august
and we go through the same stuff we went
through a few weeks ago where it's like
holy crap we were looking forward to
this and now it's not going to happen
oh i just say your idea is good though i
like your idea i just don't know if it's
realistic to lock people in one area for
basically six months i mean we could put
them in area 51 and close it down and
just have them play games there
i've joked about area 51 i mean there
are places out in the middle of nowhere
you know the greenbrier a couple of
hours from me has already three practice
fields for the new orleans saints and
later the houston texas only 710 rooms
though i was doing the math with a
couple of people in the nfl because
there are some people with teams that
are intrigued by this concept because
they understand how the dominoes could
fall to the point where you do have to
basically remove the entire league from
society in order to play the games that
has to be if
short of saying we're just going to
strap the season if they're determined
to get the season in
that really is
the last ditch effort to try to talk all
off is to remove the entire league from
circulation and uh test everybody on a
regular basis test everybody who's
bringing in the food i mean it and and
that is all premised upon having the
ability to quickly and cheaply and
efficiently test people and there's a
belief that that could be coming in the
next several months
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports